i want to make people better writers
not better plotters
what is the invisible motor the idea
that a work of art
is a mechanical thing um
that's an analogy i use but i discovered
it goes all the way back to the russian
formalists who looked at the form
rather than the content in other words
not the story but the devices you use
to make the story come alive and they
felt that a
work of art was like a machine and it
worked
as i said uh and one of the analogies
this guy used the man named victor
shlovsky
he said it was like a car and
uh he said some other things but i
go slightly slightly different direction
uh there's three things with the car
there's the engine there's the inner
structure and decor and is what the car
looks like on the outside
what the car looks like on the outside
is your story
that's your story a lot of people write
their stories and there's no
engine and there's nothing inside it's
like a fake set on a movie
you know movies lot that's the outer
trappings of it
but to me the motor that's under the
hood
that's the invisible motor that
powers a poem or story
and when you work on your story or
whatever you're going to be writing
the techniques that i teach are the
mechanics
of that invisible motor that powers
your story so that's what i mean when i
say the invisible
motor and most writing classes don't
really go to the invisible motor
they go with the design of the car the
story
how it looks from the outside but they
don't really get into writing
i want to make people better writers
not better plotters
when you're on a plane and someone says
to you what do you do
you don't say oh i'm a plotter
i want you to be you know the one who
makes the story go because of the engine
if i got in the car the most beautiful
car in the world turn on the key it
doesn't work
i don't want the car it's got to go what
makes the car go
the devices that we learn how to write
in an authentic voice then learn how to
use the other four voices
then i have other levels where i teach
other devices but these are devices
that actually facilitate the creative
unknown
and what's the oil in that engine what
if i'm low on oil
and now these gears and these different
parts are going to start grinding
and pretty soon the car is going to stop
working what is a good question no one's
ever asked me that
what's the oil whether it's synthetic
vegetable whatever i'm running on what
what is that oil that's keeping this
story
your emotional truth that's the oil
if it's not coming out of here it's not
worth
it it's just
imagination which is good up to a point
but it has to have an emotional truth
what's the emotional truth
so that's the oil okay
look at the oil you had a little while
ago that's true
i mean that was a lot of oil kiddo it
was it was an oil spill
and if you can hold on to that oil
not just for the story you would write
about being stuck
but other experiences you might write
about that that same oil
applies now your story is going to be
compelling
for the reader right you don't need an
outline
you don't need a plot you don't need
that if you don't have the deep voice
and you don't have the oil of some of
the other techniques
the emotional truth you're just
you're doing what uh uh when jack
kerouac
wrote on the road and he showed it to
truman capote it was
he wrote it on butcher paper you know
rolls a butcher paper
which you just stuck in the typewriter
uh truman capota said that's not writing
that's typing
now he was wrong but that's a good
analogy
and if you don't have the emotional
truth it's just typing
it's not writing
okay so the way you're nodding your head
yeah and but i was actually thinking of
the movie kill your darlings which
i did a show part part of it i had
jackass i was trying to
picture what he was going through i
believe he was that
his character was in the film so that's
where i went to i was thinking of
right um did he go to france and people
think he was homeless
or am i getting him talking about jack
kerouac am i getting him mixed up with
someone else where he went to france and
he became very disillusioned because
people thought he was homeless
no no i'm thinking of someone no he
lived with his mother okay
wrong person all his stories about him
being on the road
he went on the road a few times he
basically lived with his mother
and and and typed and timed but he drew
on his experiences he was a great writer
and he drew on his experiences and boy
you read on the road and
man that that book is in um the the
poetry in it
comes from the emotion of his deep voice
just
every once in a while i read the last
paragraph on the road
you just read that last two or three
paragraphs the last page
man it's great and i just read it and it
sometimes helps me find my voice
try it sometime what's this do you
remember what exactly the paragraph is
not word for word but i i can't quote it
you'd have to read it if i had it here i
could read it but um
fair enough yeah you know it's a
beautiful beautiful
piece of writing
you know it's like a piece of music
sometime i will read
a paragraph or a page out of a book that
i know the way i would put some music on
because i know it somehow gets me in the
mood or it
touches me in a certain way so
same with writing i'll read something
and it just i'll read the end of ulysses
with molly bloom's speech
where you know they're on this bluff and
he's been trying to get her to make love
to him and
finally she thinks oh what the hell as
him as anyone else what the hell
and then she asked him to ask her again
and he asked her and she said yes
i said yes i will yes
i'll read those last words and ulysses
and
man it just i hear the rhythm of that
voice and
it just really connects me there's a lot
of books things that i'll go and read
i'll read the opening of dante's inferno
midway through the journey of my life i
found myself
lost in a dark wood i found myself
lost in a dark wood how do you find
yourself
by getting lost
i midway through the journey of my life
i found myself now literally it means i
i suddenly i was there you know like
i found myself at the east uh gate i
found myself
in the back room but if you think of it
literally midway through the journey of
my life
i found myself lost
that's how i found myself by being lost
in a
dark wood you know in the dark truth of
your
soul and and of being stuck and where
you went when you went to the deep voice
that's your potent place
that's the oil that will make your
engine run
and if the engine is put together right
and you've got these techniques that you
know how to use
indy 500 winner
you